I'm gonna be blunt about this one this
list did not turn out the way I expected
it to okay folks it's Sunday that means
Doctor Who and I'm time for my monthly
list of Doctor Who related stuff and I'm
gonna do something that I have been mean
to get around to for a while and I am
gonna rank supporting characters
specifically non companion supporting
characters so basically any character
who has appeared in more than one story
reminder to partners count as one story
is eligible for inclusion on this
provided they do not meet the
requirements that I laid out for
companions also noting I am limiting
this list to the modern era I am NOT
excluding the classic era because I
don't think it's worthy of inclusion I'm
excluding it because I'm still catching
up on it I haven't seen enough of it to
be able to judge all those characters
and include them fairly
so narrowing it down to modern era and
to remind folks the way that I define a
companion is any two kinds of companions
I consider a true companion any
character who has appeared in more than
one story and actually traveled in the
TARDIS and I also have what I consider
to be one time companions which is
characters who definitely traveled in
the TARDIS
but only appeared in one story so this
is basically everybody else who is a
recurring character
so with that laid out I got one other
thing I'm going to address somebody who
actually was gonna come in at number one
on this I had to drop off the list
because I screwed up on my companion
ranking and that's Vincent van Gogh
because I forgot that day I that he did
travel on the TARDIS I forgot I don't
know how I forgot is one of the best
things the thing but when I was doing
the list
I forgot that he actually traveled in
the TARDIS to go and see that museum so
he should have been included on my list
of companions and he wasn't because I
screwed up I'm not doubling down on that
mistake which means I'm not putting him
just cuz he wasn't on the list where he
should have been so next time I redo the
companion list he will actually be on it
but so he's often once he was gone and I
took a closer look at what was going on
on this list boy yeah did not call how
look don't know if you'll be able to
hear the rain boy that's coming down
love that sound
anyway let's get to this one less thing
some of the characters I'm going to name
we do know for a fact have traveled in
time but that does not mean the same
thing as definitely having traveled in
the TARDIS because the TARDIS is not the
only way that characters can travel in
time so some of these characters were
excluded off of my companions list for
that reason because we don't know for
certain that the way they traveled in
time was through the TARDIS and some of
them are on here instead so this is the
way I have chosen to define them unless
I flat-out broke my own rules please
don't try to argue with me on the
definitions okay that's not what that
let's get blurred this so number 10 and
I'm only doing ten bits I'm not doing a
full ranking like I did with modern
companions oh is that enough caveats god
okay so number ten his shoulder now I
know my inclusion of her in anything
approaching a positive light might seem
really weird given her participation in
the abomination that is hell-bent and
honestly though I really love her second
appearance I really like her a lot in
the woman who lived do you saw that in
the girl who died but what they did when
they brought her back and the
performance given for the girl who lived
I thought that was a really neat idea
and the idea of you know a human someone
who has not had their physiology altered
in a way to accommodate the fact that
they're living way longer than they
should and the fact that basically she
runs out of memory and the only way she
can remember past stuff is to read the
house she wrote down of her past lives
because she the human brain has not made
to remember centuries and centuries and
centuries and centuries of experiences I
thought that was really interesting I
thought they rung a certain amount of
tragedy out of it the other
overall is unfortunately not great but
honestly still kind of a soft spot for
this character again despite her use in
hell-bent number nine Craig Owens I know
that there's a there seems to be a fair
amount of animosity towards the lodger
and especially towards closing time I
actually like both of those episodes I'm
neither of them are phenomenal but I
like Craig and I actually I'm generally
not a particularly big fan of James
Corbin like in general he irritates me
but I like him here I think it's just
because he's got really good performance
chemistry with Matt Smith I think that
helps a great deal and I just sort of
like the this normal guy you know who's
obviously never gonna travel with the
doctor he's not up for it but you know
trying to deal with the fact that this
guy is in his life and work with it as
best as he can and I really love at the
end of The Lodger where you know he's
asked the doctor are you lying the
doctor says of course I'm lying fair
enough
mmm and you just he just goes for it you
know to save the girl save the world you
know do what he can and I find Craig
kind of endearing I don't ever want him
to come back I don't think I think that
I think the two episodes we got was as
much as you could wring out of him but I
I rather enjoy him number eight Pete
Tyler and now when I count this I'm
actually not counting Father's Day
because I'm talking about the alternate
reality Pete Tyler the Pete's world Pete
Tyler and I like the dimension that is
granted to him I like the sense of sort
of whoa fulness about him as he you know
looks over this world you know he's rich
he's you know he's got all this power
and he's he's still not happy you know
the world just kind of yeah and then you
know finding the strength to to fight
back and and to stand up to the doctor
like from a position of of will that's a
pretty
severe rarity and I really I'm a soft
spot for him finding Jackie at the end
of towards the end of doomsday and yeah
yeah I like Pete next up number 7 Kate
Stewart now prior to series 9 back when
I was originally conceiving this list
I've been sitting on this concept for a
while she was definitely she was like
top 3 contention she is such an she's
not great in series 9 in general she's
really bad and dumb in the Zygon
two-parter and like she was first
introduced to somebody you know who has
a brain in her head and she's willing to
confront the doctor and she's got a
tactical mind which you know is just
looks at things differently from the
doctor because he's trying to avoid the
conflict she comes from that more
militaristic background and then later
on she's just dumb just willfully
ignoring him putting herself into really
stupid situations and being just really
poorly utilized as a character to the
point that I kind of wish they hadn't
brought her back for series 9 she really
she was aggravating because before that
I loved her I loved her connection to
the Brigadier I you know I loved a lot
about this character but so much of what
happened with her in series 9 just did
not work for me in any case she would
have been higher I do like her but there
you go next up number 6 Strax so I it's
hard not to blame Strax for the overall
trivialization of the Sontarans as
villains I mean it's really hard to not
blame him for that because he has
basically become the standard bearer for
them because we haven't really seen them
do anything of note I would say since
the pen
dorka opens and even then it was just
one that we saw but you know he was
still intimidating there but ever since
Strax came along he's kind of all we get
he's all we see and he has devalued the
Sontarans I still really like him as a
character I find him fun I find him
funny I love his obsession with violent
solutions and how he's always proposing
the like just the most violent option
for a problem that they have any were
just kind of looks at him like no and
then he just like oh I love that kind of
interaction I like those kinds of
characters that the the ones who just
want an excuse to let loose and they
just think they rarely kind they rarely
get it it's a shame he might be a little
bit too dumb for his own good but I do
still enjoy him number five Osgood so
yeah how do how do I cover this okay
first of all allow me to freely grant
and freely admits Osgood is the epitome
of fan pandering she is a Doctor Who fan
girl turned into a character that the
doctor himself immediately takes a
liking to that is pure fan pandering but
when it works it works then it works
here she's just she's adorable and she's
good at her job and she's focused I just
yeah it's it's really terrific and it's
been a while since I've talked about
this to answer the age-old question of
which one died which one did Missy kill
was it the Saigon or was it the human
one it's the Zygon it has to have been
because the entire premise of that
entire thing was that there is a balance
there's a human there's a Saigon both
appearing to be the same person so if
the human
died and they replace it with another
Saigon now we've got two Zygons that's
not the balance it doesn't work anymore
so the human had to have always been the
one who lived there you go I'm sure
other people will tell me I'm wrong and
explain why number four
Madame vastra she's a capable lizard
woman in Victorian England I mean like
it's hard for me to not just like that
on premise and I I like that you have
that sense of a warrior 'no sabai him
but she's kind of a climate 'add to the
time in the era certainly better than
Strax has and I like her relationships
and her interactions with the other
characters how she kind of is the
detective how she's kind of taking a bit
of a Sherlock Holmes thing going on and
I find the entire setup of who she is
and where she is placed and how she runs
her life to just be really it's pulpy
fun it is ridiculous but it's the kind
of ridiculous that I kind of enjoy
number three and I know this one's gonna
be controversial Danny pink I know a lot
of people really really don't like Danny
pink
the thing is though I've never been
entirely clear if it's because they
don't like Danny as a character or they
don't like what they feel he represents
because how he kind of stood in as a
punching bag for the doctor for him to
just beat up on soldiers sort of how he
was he forced Clara to keep coming back
so they couldn't just go out in
adventures because he was the tether
that kept forcing her to come back all
the dang time so I love it people not
liking the character or not liking the
characters effect on everything else but
I like Danny I think Danny has a great
mind on him I really like the way he
processes information and tries to cope
with the information that he gets about
what is going on around him particularly
when it comes to things like the doctor
and I think his send-off at the end I'm
sure other people find it incredibly
cheesy the idea
of basically love saving somebody from
complete conversion yes it's cheesy but
I think it works and I think he sells it
and I think in many ways it's the
redemption of the beatdown that the
doctor has been giving to him and the
whole concepts of soldiers and that kind
of service for the series up to that
point I think Danny is a strong spirit
of a character and I enjoy him and I
think he I find him likable as a
presence so I never got on the hate
train with him number two
Jenny Flint so why is this particular
member of the Paternoster gang so much
higher than the other two I don't know I
mean I don't it's hard for me to pin
this down there's just something I like
about her better than any of the others
I think what it is is how and like in it
it feeds into how I really want the
doctor to have a companion not from the
monitor I'd really like him to take
somebody from the past I would have
loved to him to have travel with the
Victorian version of car instead of the
modern era one there's something about
somebody from a period in the past who
just adapts and rolls with stuff that
you know URI
in the modern day would have a hard time
wrapping our heads around that I just
find so endearing and loving and I love
her relationship with vastra not just
because they're a kind of cute adorable
weird queer couple but I I like their
chemistry together and I like it when
Jenny just unleashes and kicks butt and
yet she still has that that's sort of
from the streets Victorian I'm just sort
of street urchin feel and vibe to her
and I like those kinds of characters you
know I grew up on stuff like Oliver
Twist and I like that sort of mentality
to a character especially when they can
be done endearingly which I absolutely
think she is so here we go with number
one and this yeah this surprised me but
the more I thought about especially once
I took Vincent off it just felt right
number one recurring naan
companion Harriet Jones I think what I
what I put her up top is she has the
most complete arc as a character form um
we first meet her to her from her lowly
position where she has no assumption
that anybody knows who she is or takes
her seriously then even when she attains
the status of power it doesn't go to her
head she takes her responsibilities very
seriously and she still has no
assumption that anyone knows who she is
but she is taking very seriously the
weight of responsibility that is on her
shoulders and even though the doctor
condemns her I feel wrongly for her
actions she also she stands by it and at
the same time doesn't hold a grudge
against him so that when she comes back
in the stolen earth and does what she
does and ultimately sacrifices herself
it's always for the greater good and
that is what she is always has on her
mind because so often when you hear
people saying for the greater good it's
a rationalization of justification for
something they want to do she really
does put her money where her mouth is
she does things that she doesn't want to
do doesn't like to do and ultimately
will result in her death because it's
what's best for the most people she
feels sincerely I think she is a well
performed well-written
strong character and I think she's the
best recurring character who isn't a
companion that modern doctor who has had
this was a much harder list to come up
with and then I thought but what are
your thoughts on these kinds of
characters is this overly specific to
that I like parse it out - - weirdly
whatever whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it you there's all the stuff
that you can do you know what it is
there's buttons and there's links down
there click as many of them as you like
the patient wants kind of the big one
but you know whatever
so just remember folks you are the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]